plus de 400 licenciés et pour nous
parler de ce sport
ta passion c'est quoi Thomas
c'est parti
Thomas est l'un des maillons forts du
beach tennis toujours motivé et
compétiteur dans l'âme cet enseignant
d'EPS s'est donné une mission faire
exister le sport qu'il aime
j'ai découvert ça dans en arrivant à la
Réunion en 2004 en traînant à la plage
de Boucan où j'étais au départ par qui
faire du beach volley tout à fait
l'histoire d'un d'une personne qui nous
a ramené le matériel le bisenix et qui
et qui nous a plus ou moins converti et
on est tous passé du tennis volley au
guichenis
même pas peur du soleil même pas peur du
vent c'est sportif de haut niveau pour
la plupart originaires du tennis profit
de la moindre opportunité pour
progresser l'objectif tournant de
Maurice tournoi de la Réunion tournoi
international en ce moment il y a du
gros niveau
on se met en place avec deux qui vont se
mettre en face et qui vont être
attaquants et si on met de défenseurs je
commence à vous alimenter en balle haute
et en ce match et puis on fera évoluer
l'exercice après quoi depuis plus de 4
ans La Réunion qu'on des champions de
France une qualité de jeu fruit d'un
engagement physique quotidien mais
accessible à tout le monde toujours
essayer de gagner du temps en attaque
comment défense ce petit temps comme
beaucoup de sport d'opposition je pense
comme les sports aussi depuis plusieurs
attaque comment défendre j'allais gagner
un petit dixième à chaque fois et au
bout de trois dixième on peut peut-être
se mettre en position d'avantage
sont avantagés pour certains points et
après les plus petits comme comme moi on
est plus vif on est un peu plus rapide
donc on fait
le petit jeu agresser